doing well at home leave what the [ __ ]
was that you don't call you don't write
you lost 30 pounds you had 24 hour
fitness 22 hours a day look at you I
don't even recognize you no more that's
right because of the Green Hornet that's
right you're nice and right mommy you
look slimmer give me a crab give it to
me look at you you're [ __ ] up muscles
month you're a savage [ __ ] Ryan you got
my main man in the house
Dennis half legendary legendary invented
[ __ ] and this beautiful girlfriend Ava
how are you telling my love of my life
I'm doing great how are you you know
we're glad to be here you know I'm so
[ __ ] ecstatic you disappointed the
bunny ranch so bad the hookers wanted to
do you when you in Reno I they wanted
you to come out and party with you you
had girls crawling all over you Stan
look at the shower
I come in a minute and a half this 20
hook is it I'm sad I wanna calm hookers
a beautiful women there well you know it
internally they call each other hookers
it's kind of a term of endearment but
working girls is the correct term but
the working girls wanted to do you I
don't want to leave their fans I want to
do and they get it I want to lead some
ass you know me I'll suck your [ __ ]
with a straw I don't give a [ __ ] nice I
don't give a [ __ ] that's my world I like
eating that ass and that monkey
inspecting you you're coming on your
neck I like all that you're an old guy
oh yeah I love it I love 69 and 82 I'll
hang you upside down and suck your
uterus ah you know me I'm a freak Jack
Cuban Ava we don't [ __ ] around weep that
monkey this part of the island that they
believe in the abattoir is that
gangsters in Italy [ __ ] can you imagine
it this idiots the idiots they'd only
push you because they feel that if you
suck a [ __ ] you suck anything so these
guys there's a little group of guys in
Cuba they call themselves how about
cause I did not know that and they can't
be in a room with a gay man there's such
men it's such a little it's a
longshoreman type organization but
they'll slice you they don't know what
they're missing
they don't think I don't hate the [ __ ]
me I'm I mean Ava can eat a [ __ ] like
unbelievable don't you mental
sees what we need to get the lately look
at least we're corfu she's already well
I you know what you tell me leaves
working hard at the 24-hour Fitness view
I think we need to get him working out
at the bunny ranch we
oh yeah we have a trainer up there and
with it we'll get those girls and here's
what be rain we got a train but here's
what I'm thinking if we get like three
or four girls hotties like like Ava and
you can go to bunny ranch calm and check
out Ava she just shot for penthouse
she's gonna be in penthouse
but if we had three or four girls and we
just kind of led them got him in tennis
shoes and Joey had to chase them and
said you're gonna get some [ __ ] in
about a mile can you imagine this guy
how fast he'd run all I could [ __ ]
run yeah I was my answer okay well Lee
Lee kichan
listen for a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] Lee
likes a little chick with a little meat
to him now did you ever live in Cuba yes
until I was three I love Cuba you've
been there I've been there many many
times I used to go there a lot I love it
and I remember the first time I went in
there I was I went to Cancun and took an
old Russian beater a Cuban airline plane
over there and when I got there the
immigration looked at me and my buddy
I'm I was with with a thug crazy clan a
tough guy and we went it we went they
took us in this room and we didn't speak
Spanish just a few words right and they
want to know why we were there and we
just said we don't believe our country
we want to see it for ourselves and so
they went they finally had a huddle they
let us in and then went to stamp our
password like no no because at that time
you go to jail okay so they put a piece
of paper in it and then they took the
piece of paper stand up the paper and
then you had that with you for the
Communist dudes they were following us
everywhere we're downtown we're doing it
every time we were with a girl that
called him off and say what are these
guys up to and they were they were on it
and it was so interesting and you talk
about girls that like to [ __ ] these
Cuban girls like the [ __ ] they like to
hit down the big thing about Cuba is
these junkets well it them bolder was
these men that came through with
can you teach a certain Cuban words
we're going to Cuba for food and I found
out that it's these guys they had there
were millionaires this is the beginning
of the Viagra age and they would get
together and go down and just bang 16
year olds they loved it then a couple of
them left their wives and brought the
[ __ ] chicks back yeah yeah one guy
left his wife [ __ ] take the kids the
house the snowmobile it's over [ __ ] I
won't some palm tree yeah give me that
Cuban monkey I you know I had I wouldn't
recommend that everybody go to Cuba and
I think they should see it because it's
really the only chance you're ever going
to see to see communism and action and
see how [ __ ] up it really is because
nobody's ever going to North Korea
except my buddy Dennis Rodman and so I
think everybody should go to Cuba just
to see how it is and and also to see the
transition because when that when that
they when the Castro moves out of the
place and it changes and becomes what it
can be it's going to be I think the rest
of the islands in the Caribbean suck
compared to Cuba well hey listen Fidel
did a lot of bad things but he also did
a good thing he kept that Beach virgin
you can't put boats in that Beach
supposedly what an end of the island I
forget
yeah that's why the water is so crystal
clear a lot of people remember at home
you'll remember Jacques Cousteau yeah 30
years ago went to Cuba and it was
beautiful chuck was still do the special
about the water I'm what they have left
FAL G and the natural plants that we've
destroyed because of the oil and [ __ ] in
the gasoline yet a water it's amazing I
mean look at why Castro's doing it
though because he's afraid you can put a
boat on they're all gonna get on the
boat get the [ __ ] out of there
[ __ ] when I go I go the girls take and
they when they want to go to the beach
and in Havana they go to go to guayaba
okay and and it cost like seven cents on
the bus and you go to the beach there
and there'd be like three or four guys
in like four or five hundred hot girls
you know and it was it was a fine I'll
of Kayla I think he was great love the
food and there's a place down in La
Cienega I'd love to go to that Cuban
Versailles yeah [ __ ] your side
that's chicken how many times we've been
in either hell had that chicken yeah
garlic house lured it knows real [ __ ]
Cuban food they had some good Cuban food
that area here where now how many
brothels do you here's what happened I
started party in there in in 76 well in
at the bunnyranch
okay called the moonlight ranch I moved
to Reno I was in the gas station
business had a bunch of gas station so I
met a girl started dating her and she
finally told me the truth she was a
hooker at the moonlight ranch so I she
said I want you to see it and so I went
out there and saw it and I said well
this is kind of cool it's kind of normal
and it's legal and so I was trying to be
a open-minded about it and like the
second time I went out there here comes
this guy Andy Kaufman and his partner
Bob zmuda the founder of comic relief
relief who's having a very sad day
because Robin Williams killed himself
today
and so I met them and Andy and they
lined up the girls 28 girls and Andy
couldn't pick a girl and Bob's like pick
one come on fix I can pick one I'm
watching this he says no he says I I
can't hurt anybody's feelings I will
pick a girl and I will party with her in
fact I want to pick two girls and and I
wanted to wrestle each other and and
then whoever wins I have sex with but I
will party with all of you in the next
week I'm playing at Harris at the lake
and so I met Kaufman and and we became
friends and Bob and I started hanging
there a lot in about 78 conferences you
know what excuse prostitution worldwide
is is Gideon get up get off get [ __ ] out
of here that's just that's just how it
is
Kaufman said let's buy this place turned
it into our den and treat everybody like
you and I are treated me because I was a
boyfriend Kaufman because he was a giant
celebrity I mean the time Saturday Night
Live is everything in taxi it was huge
it was much bigger than sitcom comic
nowadays because there wasn't many of
them and so I said Wow so we started
putting our notes together our ideas
together and I tried to buy it couldn't
get it done
Hoffman died in 84 doesn't drink doesn't
smoke vegetarian died of cancer and I
kept working and got it 92 bought it and
I just took the the playbook that we
came up with and turned it into the most
famous place in the world and by using
all the things that me and Kaufman put
together so this is the difference
between every other brothel you would go
to and your bra just ate your daddy's
old cathouse this is this is fun
it's a shame all your listeners can't
look because Ava adora is unbelievably
beautiful and I'm watching they got
cameras oh they're watching okay great
hey how you doing
kitschy short tips yeahbsolutely
whatever she wants to do I want to see
some titty now look at these things
Joey look at these tremendous large
large Portuguese boobies I need
tremendous yes real look at those things
they are people put on to do people stay
up there for well girls come in and stay
a few weeks or a few months I mean some
of them for years like she came up there
she went to Boston University and
graduated and that she wants to be a
doctor we've got a bunch of like a whole
bunch of school loans right yeah I have
a lot of school loans a lot of degrees
you know but I thought that before I
take the next step and go on to you know
go to residency and go to practice I
should save some more money up so that's
why I'm here
been having fun yeah exactly you know
how long do guys usually stay up there
for well I mean it can be as short as 10
minutes it could be as long as six
months yeah no [ __ ] yeah yeah we had a
guy come in at Christmas a couple years
ago and start partying and I told the
girl says he you know what there's I
could I'm always there because I feel
like the girls that are working are
there on Christmas need a family and we
are their family and so I need to be
there so it's a time I should be
traveling but I never do and this guy
came in and he's 65 but he was like 165
is not old in this day and age and but
he was like a hundred and and so he he
sat there and talked to us for a while
and I said you're gonna stay and have
dinner with us he's okay
and went to the bathroom I told the
girls that you get this this we're going
to make sure this guy is the best
Christmas he's ever had
all right and because there's a karma
that goes with this and our whole next
year we'll be lucky the guy started
partying and spent two million four
hundred thousand dollars he was there a
couple months and it was generous given
girls ten thousand a day and it's net
and you don't have to do that me you
spend a few hundred or a few thousand
and depending on what you want to do
there who you want to do it with what
you want to drink and how long you want
to be there and the girls work with the
guys budgets and this guy dropped 2.4
million dollars and so month yeah two
months when you start you start giving
two three four five girls five to ten
thousand dollars a day it adds up quick
and he wanted a bunch of girls with him
at all times you know in fact he called
his mom now his mom had to be 85 or 90
and is an over a speaker phone and his
mom says honey are you gonna spend all
your money there and all the girls are
listening these is probably you know
just having a good time yeah that's all
this it's yeah it's that's what it's
about people can be themselves no matter
what what you whatever you want to do if
all you want to do is just raise the bar
from your relationship with your wife
because because it can get a little bit
boring after a while with we all know
we've all been there not to say that's
the girl's fault it's the guys fault too
but it gets a little boring a guy wants
to try some variety he wants to try a
different position every man's every
man's a fantasy is a threesome having
two hot chicks Naughton what they better
than one Ava is to Avis and and guys
come in and they can be what they want
can't they it's so true yeah and I mean
and it's just the fact that you know we
keep your secrets we can you know we all
know
things about our clients and people who
come in that nobody else in their life
knows about let me give an example let
me give you example we keep the secret
so like if it's Lee came in okay and Lee
wanted us to pull out the pony cart
because we have a pony cart that we
could put him on but some tennis shoes
naked and we could strap him to the
rails and then he could pull Ava around
the parking lot and but actually what
we've read probably Ava's Ava's got a
two foot long horsehair butt plug and
she could put that so he could just
whinny around the parking lot holla
daiva and are pretty ass around there
and okay be doing it and we wouldn't
tell anybody see that that's the beauty
of privacy and discretion nobody would
know that Lee has a horse vanish never
now you find out you fetish I kind of
[ __ ] do you find that I like eating
[ __ ] I'll pull your hair you know how
your audience call you some names
nothing [ __ ] no I feel [ __ ] bad I
don't know I've always had that cat what
what people like this would you kill
what I did blow and drank I was a nasty
freak I'd take my dick out jerk-off on
your neck on your feet like that but I
never really got crazy like somebody
dressing up would it be I don't
understand well but and different
different strokes for different folks
like I'm the same way when I'm with a
girl you know I want her to have many
orgasms because I want to feel like a
hero okay I I want to eat [ __ ] I want
to [ __ ] or try a few different positions
I'd rather have the girl on top cowgirl
or maybe reverse cowgirl you know I can
slap her butt a little bit
what's doing it and I'm a pretty pretty
simple guy but every day somebody comes
in there we had a guy just recently and
Ava saw this guy she was a part of this
the guy comes in and rings the bell and
I looked at the monitor and he looked
like my PE coach like a 6-1 buff tough
guy right blond flattop and he comes in
it but he's wearing a nun's outfit
smoking a cigarette and I like yeah this
is gonna be a good day and so he comes
in and a lot of girls line up and and
they should pick a girl and he says oh
no no no I want to be a girl and Ava so
smart she says to him good I handle the
applications come with me so she takes
him to the office is if we need an
application she wants to go to work for
us and it spits 300 all our application
fee and so then she fills out the
application and takes takes the guy to
madam Suzanne and say this nun would
like to work here and so Suzette
interviews her and they hire her and she
said we got to do some about wardrobe
here and so Ava took him to the office
is it it's $200 for the war trophy and
so they got him in there and it shaved
his legs and did all the things that
they did put him in in thigh-highs
mm-hmm he looked like looked like Vince
Neil was a long blonde wig like Vince
Neil's ugly sister okay
convinced by the way Vince comes to the
ranch he was there a couple of weeks ago
a motley crew was in town and so then
then Ava puts a puts her at the bar and
says we'll start working and and then
then it's like a little while later said
hey you can't just sit here and look
pretty around here you got to work get
the line up so the guy she had the guys
getting the line up okay
and that was fun wasn't it it was so
much fun and he left very happy you know
that that's the kind of explain a minute
he did get fired I mean you took your
office I told Suzette you didn't think
she was gonna work out and Sue's that
fired her that's hysterical yeah but but
you know what he was who he wanted to be
for that moment exactly and and we all
we all are gonna have those kinks at
different times and just like like
Lina's Pony fetish
I mean who would know who would know no
one's looking nope nobody nobody gets it
now let me ask you just describe what
cuz you were talking about a madam from
A to Z what happened I knock on the door
who greets me Wow
who's gonna greet you is one of our
staff members you're gonna have your
choice if we call it the doho yes or or
[ __ ] um and she's gonna ask you if you
if you have an appointment if you know
who you want to see if you'd want to
line up if you just want to go to the
bar from there if you choose to have a
line up all the girls who are working on
shift come out and we you know meet and
greet just like I don't you know a rock
and roll concert hi I'm Eva hi I'm Emily
hi I'm did it uh let's say I want to go
to the bar just hang out for now right
then it becomes the best singles bar in
the entire world you know then it's our
job is working your odds are good to you
and you and we'll talk to you for five
minutes and we you know we rob we have
to let the off every girl talk to you
until you choose who you want to go slow
to negotiate and if you never choose a
girl that's fine
as long as you have a good time I guess
what what we we're different than other
brothels around the world because they
don't want guys to do that I want to do
that because I know the guys going to go
back and brag to his friends that he
[ __ ] Aven ten different positions and
all that and then the friends are going
to go to bunny ranch calm they're gonna
look at it and one of his friends are
going to come up to see her because it's
it's because that's what that's the way
men are we want to brag about our
conquests and all that so we just come
in and have a good time you want to want
to party what we call sex partying
whether it's the pony cart the nun with
a cigarette with no moral it's a [ __ ]
snuggling whatever it's a party that's
what we call it and because that's a
term we can use on O'Reilly and Hannity
in the view and things like that so they
do that and guys hang around there and
some party some don't as long as
everybody goes away having fun that's
that's all we care about and and then if
they want a party of course the girls
it's their job to entice you to go to
the room and then there's there's a menu
got a menu that we we can the girls use
to create more than just the missionary
experience and another one okay and just
then the missionary experience and so
there's there's a ask Ava if you're
confused about any of the items menu
items Ava can explain it to you
unbelievable to go orders military
discount to girl party how many girls
are there one time well there's always
30
there's always 30 but now in Northern
Nevada between Reno and Lake Tahoe
there's only four brothels I own all of
them so we have like a hundred girls
working at all times then the different
brothels the the bunny ranch is the
flagship it's the most well-known
because of the HBO cathouse series and
everybody knows about the bunny ranch
you'd have to be living under a rock
yeah
not to her now Lee Lee knew about us
when he was 14 yeah yeah I was asking
you when I can't when I came on he said
2004 all right - mm - so yeah so I was
like 14 16 um and we didn't have HBO at
the house so when we go on vacation my
brother and I would get our own room and
they'd HBO would send stuff to the hotel
something like this like saying what's
gonna be on HBO and have real sex or the
bunny ranch was one was on it was a good
night cuz yeah that was like the first
almost first experience to porn would
you had almost [ __ ] blow up yeah it
watch the naked what was it show there
was a girl I remember the only thing I
remember like a girl who dressed up like
she's in the Air Force Air Force Amy
airforce Amy it was she don't work it
she is the Michael Jordan of sex it's
true wherever you wear every year at
sexually she's gonna take you up a
couple notches if you want to I mean she
can be sweet and loving and caring and
all that but she can also she'll take
you up wherever wherever you think
you're at we all we all think that we're
kinkier than we really are
and every day somebody Trump's me every
I mean you get guys come in there that
one
I wanted to be trampled he wanted 12
girls to trample him some in tennis
shoes some in flat some in spikes so
much stilettos so low to the face and
stuff what do you want to be warm really
wanted it and that way that was this
deal and and the girls told me his dick
got hard as Chinese arithmetic we keep
when they were walking on it right and
we get girls the guys that want to be
their feminine best and get interests up
we had an MMA guy in there with Brooke
ones and it actually broke some
handcuffs and he wanted her to go out to
his truck and get a 2x4 right now that's
where we draw the line look you by force
no [ __ ] it dude when I go for that so
but the point is you can be who you want
to be while you're there
without anybody judging you you want it
you want to wear a skirt you want to be
silly you want a dog collar we you know
even had a guy a couple weeks ago she
had on a dog collar you know a little
riding crop and walking him through the
parlor and he loved it and so I mean you
really got off one that did it oh yeah
oh yeah he picked his dog name you know
he didn't want to be able to use the
restroom indoors he was very very slow
yes'm what was his dog name it was low
fee no he can't know that yeah
affectionately yeah
like I just joined you Jitsu and it's
very hard for me I'm in there for 15
months but I always was kind of athletic
like I play basketball football in high
school and I went to karate from very
flexible I just want to do something
different but I had an aptitude for it
you know I do not have a nap
for cars like if my car gets a flat I'll
[ __ ] leave that [ __ ] then go
buy a new what a reporter stole it comes
up all changes as [ __ ] like that
State Farm did you hear that I am I have
no habitude for sex
even as a young what happened to me was
when I was about 17 we were hanging out
with these guys one night and they go
it's Pedro Briana's birthday party and
at that time I had [ __ ] them in some
ass [ __ ] like no I ain't [ __ ] nobody
had ever sucked my dick I was very prude
and I went into this place until the
city was called the 10/40 Club this is
back at New York City we're going 1981
and basically it was a moratorium on the
west side where it cost $9.99 to be with
a girl plus tax
1040 so it was called the 1040 club you
pay 10 dollars and 40 cents they gave
you a ticket you went in this was
something a guy to this day it was one
of the worst experiences of my life I
went home was like almost done with sex
well some people have those bad
experiences and that's why we're there
with a lot of the girls are into
training and and and teaching people and
and and being it but that was tricking
sure I know that I know they know though
yeah I know the place
episodes 10:40 oh my god no this was a
[ __ ] team so this was isn't she 200
men drunk smell of Cologne hey what's up
I get my dick sucked every night well
why are you here then you know those
type of guys right 200 there are no
girls there they open up a door and they
start pushing our girls this is like
you've been trafficking they push him on
you got to grab them you got to drag
them to the guy give them a ticket then
they take it to this back room that's
like a [ __ ] Vietnam tent with
petitions and the little little beds
that that the ones that open up again
grandmother comes over and you open it
up and you know a whole guy in a cot and
they would wash it dick this is 1981
would take your dick out talk it's a
fast house oh my god this was something
that I was petrified and she washed my
dick she put a condom on and I was like
having anxiety attack well at that point
I was into deer she got on top of me
this lady took off her stockings it look
like she had been stabbed to drag by a
[ __ ] car it was just a [ __ ] horror
show and I'm on the bottom I believed in
love I believe that you know that with
flowers [ __ ] why I don't [ __ ] know
I used to dry up Vicky to Earth Wind &
Fire when I was the 6th grade I sucked a
little [ __ ] dick and all the side I
got this woman on top of me bouncing and
I can hear the condom heater acting on
my dick and I'm about to [ __ ] puke a
little said she stops and she goes for
an exit technology go down on me and I
took a [ __ ] hip and I go you gotta go
and I will my friend I left my friends I
thought they took a bus over New York
City and I was your number 36 for the
day for her I was mummified like I was
17 I was mummified yeah and I didn't we
want to have sex after that for a while
and this gal this is such a it's amazing
terrible I know this gal oh yeah nothing
what do you party with I know the gal
she's been in prison like 25 times she's
in right now she's gone and and I I did
it I did an undercover thing for ABC
News and so I'm looking for a sex
trafficking of underage girls so I went
to different places over in and not the
Bronx what's the other one Roosevelt
Street Brooklyn Queens Queens and so I
found a place over there where they had
these 13 and 14 year old girls and it
was disgusting it was but that's what I
was looking for so I found this place
and I went in there and and she had like
four girls and it's like you say she is
but she wasn't doing anything wrong it's
all illegal and when the illegal it
means there's drugs it means
it's just terrible it's like anybody
that anybody wants to play Russian
roulette go to backpage.com and pick a
girl off there you're going to get
arrested you get robbed you're going to
get diseased something bad is going to
happen so I did this and I ended up that
night at the Comedy Cellar because I run
around with comics because all I want to
do is laugh come and have a burger once
in a while that's all I want to do it's
BK and and so I'm down there with my
buddies Jim Norton and and rich Voss and
Colin Quinn and all the guys right and
so I start telling the story about this
place
Colin's like tennis was that called
episodes 1040 I said yep he's I went
there for like 40 years ago okay
it was like a place everybody went but
yeah that but our place is it's
different it's like it's like dating
it's really like dating yeah we're the
opposite of that that sounds like a
horror oh it is but that's when you make
something illegal well exactly listen
this is the same thing as Al Capone in
the gangsters you know during
Prohibition who made the money
the gangsters made the money the
politicians they got paid to look the
other way made the money when you make
it legal then it brings the incredible
people like myself with nice girls you'd
never see a girl like I gave up working
in this toilet you're talking about and
and that that's the difference that's
this is why we have to legalize this
business to stop the sex trafficking and
and given young guys like you a terrible
experience oh my god it was and I never
recovered sexually I could be honest for
everybody we got to change their tales
it sexually get you up there very uh we
can fix that not helping over completely
Lisa but when you're around when you're
around nice people and the girls are are
having fun
you'll just be there yeah they want to
be there and they're just you're gonna
you're gonna track guy girls like funny
guys that's it's just that's uni and
nice I tell I tell guys my buddies one
code Thursday what do we do how do we do
say here's what you do first of all
you'd be clean and you'd be respectful
and you and you have a good time girls
want to laugh when the girls laughing
you're close to her [ __ ] okay and in
this case because you're paying for it
the quality of the part
is going to go up the price is going to
go down and but they love comics he
loved the laughs they love to giggle and
have a good time we're gonna fix you
know I gotta get fixed this is at least
my last [ __ ] ten years of existence
but yeah I was talking about you talk
about martial arts I was talking about
that last night my buddy I was at the
rainbow with my uncle Hal over here and
in Chuck Zito and we were sitting around
talking about that Chuck is is doing
doing that jujitsu and you know Chuck's
a boxer yes and you know he was at
metamoris this weekend I was a
tournament and I saw he was there with
the guy I studied with Hagen Machado
really and it's amazing that I got it I
never thought he'd [ __ ] meds feet all
right the last thing I ever want is a
man's ass in my face I'm [ __ ] old
school I don't want her nuts by my face
I don't give a [ __ ] that's why they
invented guns they understand exactly
they invented machine guns so there's no
jujitsu but I wanted something different
and when I came from Cuba my mother
signed me up in karate
I've been punching and kicking and then
when I lost 100 pounds and punched and
kicked and I was done and it was a Jitsu
school it was cheap and I said let me go
in there the first day I walked in there
my face was that [ __ ] red was nothing
compared to what my face was obviously
batting here 100 pounds overweight let
me tell you something else if I'm not
doing it I'm at home watching videos
really I'm getting surgery on my knee
just so I could get to the next [ __ ]
level Wow that's how much I like it cuz
I'd know if I do that three days a week
I will lose 150 frames I don't feel
great even if I just one egg a day for
breakfast might keep it normal
I will lose it's that much here here's
the trick I was at the Playboy Mansion
getting a picture taken with a fan and
drunk girl ran from behind me leaped up
I heard her call my name I turned my
head arms around my neck legs around my
waist and pulled me down and blew my
knee out I had to have a full knee
replacement okay so I went to male
best place in the world Mayo Clinic in
Rochester and and what do we do is well
you got to get a knee replacement but if
you if you want to increase the chance
of success you got to get the weight off
and and build your quads and so the
trick was no starches no sugars no soda
pops and guess what the weight falls off
it falls off if you if you just don't
eat starches starches are the killer
they're killing America they're in
flaming everything and that the pain
went way down on my knee when I got
those starches out of my system because
you didn't have the information and so I
lost 73 pounds by doing what we're
talking about and so those are you guys
listen if you want to take off some
weight stop the [ __ ] start just stop
the sugars and instead stop the soda
pops and guess what the weight falls off
you let me ask you this just not to get
off the subject Robin Williams oh my
goodness what the [ __ ] happened say I
love Robin and you know what and I got
to tell you I've been around them all
Robins my favorite and Robert Robbins
Robins my favorite and he's a great guy
he's a fun guy and I can't imagine with
all the success that he's had with comic
relief and all the movies turned into a
big movie star what the [ __ ] now I just
called Bob zmuda founder of comic relief
my dear friend and because people are
calling me saying we want Bob on CNN we
won a money today's show so I know all
these people so they're calling me and
I'm hooking him up with Bob I can't
imagine what what it would take to want
to officiate a guy that's got the world
by the ass it's not money
he's got the fame every everybody likes
like Robin Williams I don't get it it's
mental illness you know and it's the
whole concept of being the tears of a
clown you know the funniest guy in the
room is you
Leoben the saddest guy in the room at
one point and you got a nose always been
depressed like he's always battled
depression it's just wrong Williams yes
oh yeah so here denies I said that I
know he checked into a rehab about two
years ago he was just there the summer
actually heard drugs and three shots
something was going on that we didn't
know about the a CBS show yeah or BC it
cancelled it and they said the show
wasn't bad so I am nothing he does yeah
I assume that either his salary was too
high for network television or look
something was up they would just get rid
of this Robin Williams show if it wasn't
something motto my favorite story with
Robin I've been around him because of
Bob zmuda I've been around him and but
this goes back a long ways so Kaufman
plays Carnegie Hall and he comes out and
he gives his heartfelt speech about how
he I dream was to always when he was a
kid that he would play at Carnegie Hall
and nobody believed him except his
grandma and and I want my birth grandma
to be here with me so grandma comes out
and and everybody standing ovation for
grandma she's the one that believed in
him he says and I want grandma to be
comfortable so we flew her couch out and
bring the couch out grandma's crying oh
my
wonderful moment her grandson is at
Carnegie Hall and so every throughout
the show he would reference her
Instagram of how we doing and all and so
at the end of the show he says I'd like
to have my good the reason I'm here is
because my grandma believed in me I'd
let grandma would you stand up and take
a take a bow so grandma stood up the
whole place standing ovation
grandma grabs her wig pulls it off pulls
off the mask and it's Robin Williams
yeah amazing yeah so I I don't I don't
know but I think even if you're right if
it's mental illness it's a terrible
thing with all these shootings and all
this craziness and that we can't advance
as our country is that we can't get this
mental illness thing under control
because what a lost a lost humanity
Robin Williams is exactly this event as
a comedian you go to these weird places
you know we all do you have self-doubt
you have all these things so who knows
what could happen I read
growing up and there was some dark place
I never thought about Isaac myself I
don't know why I always thought I'd be
like you never you never know I mean we
we had something happen this last year
we did a promotion with a jackass
bad grandpa okay month-long promotion
with our CERN and and grandsons and
granddaughters would have to call in and
and say why their grandpa should get to
go to the bunny ranch free trip to the
bunny right got it down to three the
grandsons and granddaughters brought
their grandpa's into Stern studio I'm
there with a couple of our girls
Crescent kisses rain riches and so
they're interviewing them and Robyn's
crying because one guy had cancer and
she you know she's had her cancer thing
and Howard's like these guys are nice as
my [ __ ] dad I love these guys and so
it was sad they're only one person one
so then the girls are like daddy daddy
we want all of them to come and like
well what are you going to do for me and
yeah Howard says yeah what are you going
to do for him if all the grams has come
and Howard says a threesome as we did
that last night our what oh yeah we
already did that and so it was great so
anyway the first grandpa comes there by
Xion we get him there gets in the limo
he comes to the ranch 86 years old
grandpa Johnny you met all the girls in
our party our weekly Tea Party and now
it's time to party you know I want to go
have a steak and so he goes to a casino
Harvey's casino and it's a Jew room
amazing restaurant has two bites of a
prime rib and dies in the restaurant
chokes on a piece of prime rib okay the
grandson is a Parks and Rec professional
knows Heimlich know CPR
can't get him the security team at the
casino can't get him back the paramedics
work on him for 45 minutes done done
deal so you just you never know so
that's why you want to have fun every
day of your life
if you think you want to do something
don't hesitate you do it
yep alibi the same [ __ ] you got a go for
it yeah cuz you never know I've had a
lot you know every morning when I wake
up I have a couple pictures of friends
of mine that died we were in like in
high school no grammar school I still
talk to the family but every time I have
a doubt about something I look at that
[ __ ] picture you know cube I always
think about when I'm eating the sandwich
and I'm like right now my family's eat
the negative six ways yeah to read the
[ __ ] egg six of them looking at a let
go okay
let's chop it up six ways you could open
up a water [ __ ] I love Cuban sandwiches
oh my god is there a good place in town
to get a B sales I open till 8:00
o'clock I open Burbank right down the
block
Porto's [ __ ] trim maybe I can go
tomorrow daddy Pat oh [ __ ] I love it
we're gonna go the guy's a Cuban guy had
opened one in Glendale that's Oh nope
there's no Cuban Xena it's all Armenian
he's got a Cuban bakeries not he popped
one and Lee was just there to get a cake
for his in-laws
I bought oh man [ __ ] tremendous they
don't play games you stand best time
there Danny goes 10:45 for the rush
there's nobody there
does nobody there yep oh I'll take my
little [ __ ] Ron Jeremy because she can
eat she could hope she can [ __ ] eat
this one take me daddy I don't see Roger
here gothic God nice toys is seeing or
walking into the bank I know you can't
run walking into the bank and he goes to
Bank of America and so say Yahoo block
east of Laugh Factory
there you go offer Fairfax yeah he's
coming in with his little [ __ ] car
yeah and those a bag of signals and [ __ ]
toy car that is the only car in America
that's never been washed never wash the
car that car that's what holds ridicu
that's what holds the car together is
the dirt you really have to love the
mystique of ron jeremy oh he's just a
he's a walking cartoon character
[ __ ] we this thing in the world why can
you can you imagine that like God mother
nature whoever whoever puts all this
together yes sir okay let's let's build
a little Harry Judy and and and let's
let's let's just make her disheveled
yeah I wanted to be about sixty pounds
overweight that's what I'm kind of
thinking will get her a good education
and and and you know what just to give
her a chance miss put a ten inch [ __ ] on
her you know because that can you
imagine that that's ron jeremy somebody
sitting up there smoking a fat one
saying ellis let's do something fun
today put this deal together and the
mystique no matter where the [ __ ] he
goes somebody runs up to him that walks
but Sprint's up to him and says gonna
have an autograph
you know people come people cut the
[ __ ] california from Ohio or Indiana
Ohio or whatever [ __ ] they're coming
from and they go to Hollywood Boulevard
think about this and they walk around
and they're looking for Brad Pitt
Angelina Jolie and one night they end up
going to SAP bagel place yeah whatever
you see ron jeremy every [ __ ] guy as
i go back to work when his wife's not
around and go custer guys he's like
[ __ ] the present he's like the
[ __ ] present this is not this is our
fear if you're a [ __ ] freak and you
like to [ __ ] this is your feel asleep
this is one of the first guys you really
caught [ __ ] and sucking and coming on
somebody's your fearless leader this is
your fearless leader
this is the [ __ ] leader of the free
world if you want to [ __ ] suck if
you're 40 and under you learn how to do
something from rod [ __ ] jeremy unless
you unless you were [ __ ] molested but
i love you you learn how to do something
what do you love him
jeremy what do you remove you learn from
wrong what the [ __ ] you learned
something cuz i again because of my
sexual dysfunction as a young man we're
gonna fix that i did not like the other
[ __ ] that one you know when i was a kid
again you find your father's real real
date millimeter
young for that oh yeah you know eight in
those days you ordered water they sent
you to projector in the mail you order
three films they didn't have magazines
they had magazines but I've ever New
York City the funniest magazine they had
was a head of auto Rican magazine called
pika-pika
it was Puerto Rican chicks and they had
big asses that was black and white but
they cover their faces hysterical his
staring over they would cover their face
in a paper bag on yes terrible we
everybody had the magazine but you know
okay well who one of my men are my
mentors are Andy Kaufman right oh my god
master of the goof and I and I I goof on
on the underworld I'm always I'm always
using telling you are walking [ __ ]
goof I can't believe I [ __ ] with I [ __ ]
with everything I mean Obama goes to
Columbia the guys get caught with the
hookers and I'm doing a press release an
hour later saying you know you know I'm
concerned about the welfare of our
president but the bigger thing is these
Secret Service guys need to buy American
booty they need to buy it the Buddy Rich
by America
I mean I'm if there's an angle out there
Donald sterling gets himself in trouble
I get a few of my buddies from the NBA
contact me and I band this guy six hours
before the NBA did a lifetime ban from
the bunnyranch took him up my birthday
list and and so we're always looking for
the angle and and there's there's some
great ones great ones out there to just
make make it all funds because all I
want all I want the world to do is know
about the bunny right because the best
customer and the best working girl
doesn't even know the bunny ranch exists
and so it's my job to tell the world and
and then beautiful girls like Ava take
care of their clients one [ __ ] at a time
Ava let me ask you this yes sir
disrespect me I come in there I got
$10,000 and I don't want to [ __ ] I don't
want to I just want to eat somebody's
[ __ ] [ __ ] so the head pops out what
happens how do I know this is USDA fresh
meat I'm not gonna get a third tongue up
Thursday little blister is something
like that I'm going deep into the murky
waters a very [ __ ]
and your [ __ ] when I [ __ ] without
siling to suck my dick nut I just want
to eat [ __ ] what happens well in order
to be a working girl at the bunnyranch
people think that it's kind of it you
walk in if you're hot you know we put
you on the floor and that's that it's
very opposite you know we can't have a
felony or any kind of anything on our
medical record for the last five years
you know we we get tested every week for
every STD Under the Sun we passive you
know a rigorous application process that
you know Madame Suzette and Dennis put
on you know a thousand girls hit the
button a month and there's 30 rooms
thousand girls month want to go to work
and and we hire you know like 20 girls
rotate correct yes I remember then
though we'll see you next you said it
was about 500 or 540 girls now it takes
to keep 120 workers at all times you
have the four clubs dirty girls in North
in Northern Nevada f4 and Southern
Nevada have three so those smaller clubs
and their works in progress but they're
outside of Vegas like that like an hour
outside of Vegas and but that's but as
far as its cleanliness there's just no
problems at all I mean these girls are
tested and put a girl wouldn't run on go
this [ __ ] overweight guy once eat my
[ __ ] till the hand comes out no no
she'd go to and it'd be putting cherries
on there they'd be putting whipped cream
crunchies like what do you like on like
on your on your poonanny today and you
can make a sundae out of these girls
right and just because and there's a
beauty of that to it especially for
merry guys eating a cheat okay that's it
that's not that's not that's not cheap
damn you didn't know that did you know
and the other thing there's a law in
Nevada law and not a lot of people know
this I need the listeners to understand
it when you walk through the gates at
the bunnyranch
your marriage is annulled for the period
of time you're inside for as long as you
negotiate yeah for a long as you're
inside the ranch you're know so there's
no guilt right with you and your
Catholic guilt thing we got to watch you
you need to put make an app so you can
you show this to your girlfriend like no
this is where he said there's a law and
like explain it because like yeah we
charge up you know I before I should
know to you know that we bill discreetly
so that if your wife or your girlfriend
does you know check your finances or you
guys have a joint account she it doesn't
say you know bunnyranch hookers thousand
dollars for anal data you know or
whatever it may be like on there I'm
gonna give you a free idea I'm gonna
give you a VIP comp which means a spaz
booty pass and I want you to have it in
your pocket it's kind of like having a
triple-a card
you have triple-a yes okay and you don't
use it very often but you got the card
with you this it's the same way in the
case there's an emergency in case your
wife doesn't want to do some dirty
disgusting thing that you want to do
that day you've got it for emergency
purposes to pull it out and say honey
that's okay but I can go I can go use
this Dennis gave me this ass pass and I
go use that would you rather have me do
that you wait you wait how fast you
wants to get naked that's caught that
solves that whole problem believe me
it's just amazing you always getting an
ass pass let me ask you something that
you have girlfriends you will bury at
one time right how did this fly at home
it didn't obviously I got married I lied
you know that Chuck Zito and I were
talking about - you know what we're I
know Chuck pretty well but we never
talked about really personal things
right excuse me look so Chuck like me
got married when he was 17 and because I
got married young I had a lot of
responsibilities and so all I did all I
did was work go to school and [ __ ] I
mean that's all I did because I didn't
have the money to do anything so I never
got into drugs never got into alcohol I
don't drink don't smoke don't smoke
except the cigar and and never did any
drugs I just I just want to I want sex
and throw me a Cuban sandwich and I'm
happy right so so that's it and Chuck
and I ran that same parallel because he
doesn't drink I mean what a what a crazy
thing that a Hells Angel doesn't get
into drugs because that's what they're
known for
right and what he never got into
anything he's just straight as can be
and it's so and so am I so you know all
I want to do is have sex I want to I
want to laugh and and like I love
hanging out with comedians because
comedians first of all they're all
[ __ ] sick okay and that that's fits
right into my world and and anyone
laughs so laughing coming and and and
and have a little food once a while and
and I'm a happy guy and I think you'd
agree with that wouldn't you oh yeah
yeah yeah
are you a date Heidi Fleiss for Mom this
is old news I know your father died
how do you know were all right yes we
were they were fuck-buddies we're never
like boyfriend/girlfriend but we
secretly would get together and fool
around and then we we got caught by some
paparazzi and and ended up going to New
York to try to clean it up a little bit
and saying we're just friends and all
that and so we did Fox oh we did
we did Sean Hannity show and just all
these things so we're on Howard Stern
and and she said the greatest line
because Howard's like okay how long is
this going on this is the cathouse King
brothel baron you're the Hollywood men
you went to a penitentiary for
prostitution
she's what the hell is your sex life
like and Heidi thought for a second
she's this Howard he's done with me I
don't know where they ask him to marry
me or call 911 and every time I see
Howard he says anyway called 9-1-1 onion
he never forgot that line right but
Heidi's good I love Heidi and I'm always
bailing around at some little Jam
because he's always getting but Heidi's
so greatest she's wonderful she's fun
and tonight I'm honored to say she's my
friend she's of course fighting the
demons with with drugs and it's she's so
unique because this is a chick that
never not one time in her life has ever
been in a fast food restaurant nobody
can say that and nobody I know could say
that she has never been in a fast food
restaurant and she eats twigs and nuts
and pistachios I was I was driving over
here from Vegas and I had a bag of
natural almonds on salted almonds I took
a picture of it and oh my god you
thought I bought her a car oh that's so
[ __ ] cool that is how my god I'm so
proud of you I've eaten the unsalted
almonds up in the car right impotent but
then she has her thing with drugs and
it's just it just it's really
unbelievable and she's okay now but
she'd be she's I'm not putting any
secret out there that people don't know
I mean she's been on Celebrity Rehab and
she's not got a lot of things but you
would love I'll get her in here someday
we'll have some fun with she's the
greatest she not a fan of hers from
slowly rehab I couldn't believe she was
involved with Tom Sizemore like
got it you know tom was a great actor
for a long time but he [ __ ] just and
it's amazing how we all go through I bow
to that [ __ ] you're very fortunate never
Lee has never you don't leave smoked
when we met that we smoked - I give him
edibles yeah then I gave up
chocolate-covered mushrooms at the
Comedy Store even taught me but I
cleanse so he leave okay so you just
give me stuff you just gave us to take
it I put my mothership what was that
didn't taste like weed you like it's
mushrooms I've never done much before oh
that's me there were tremendous cotton I
didn't take enough I don't think he in
his defense he didn't give me like a
small piece no I was looking at come on
and you spoke to him since I was 14
you started smoking when you're 14 we
know cigarettes like moved to Los
Angeles huh I always my mother had a bar
we had a Cuban born you didn't see New
Jersey
it was the second-biggest Cuban
community in the country really 1950 on
because of the embroidery business in
New Jersey so when you landed in Miami
there was billboards that said the land
of opportunity you didn't say in New
Jersey so he needed a scapegoat like my
53 and my father became like the first
Cuban committeeman he hold the sandwich
shop called the okay restaurant by
Washington School on 38th and New York
aminal did he have the Cuban sandwiches
yeah the Cubans ran from 7th Street 248
about four blocks over from Bergen play
enamel that was all Cuban we walk in
Jersey City but the Cubans so my mom had
a bar there it was a successful bar and
for some reason I just never liked the
I just watched me love an early age you
know I used to dip my pacifier
blackberry brandy and [ __ ] like that but
I got I stole a bottle of wine when I
was like three four and I drank
something well I got ended up in the
closet oh just something my mom called
the cops and they found me in the
diapers [ __ ] oh [ __ ] all over be a puke
so it's David me and I'll tell you what
will I go out at night I swear to God
every time I go out I go tonight I'm
gonna have a cocktail there's nothing
that tastes better than a [ __ ]
margarita not to get drunk just for the
flavor yeah you know sometimes I go to
Rudy's Jersey to eat the the fried squid
the Calabar I got a Heineken on tap it's
delicious I just don't like drinking to
get [ __ ] habit it doesn't make me
it's not nothing I'm against how jeez I
don't like that I just don't drink cuz I
don't like the flavor I love to do a
shot of Jager with you if I drink my
friend said to me how many describe on
one hand how many times you drink in a
yob drink three drinks a year two of
those would be shots maybe a cocktail to
go off the deep end or something like
that and you know I I just have I just
never got into it like if we were out
and somebody wanted to order a bottle of
wine I'd have like a third of a glass
and I'd act like I'm I'm having a big
good time with it you know and but it's
about the taste you think if they come
up with something that makes liquor
tastes like something from Dairy Queen
oh [ __ ] guess what I'm an alcoholic
yeah me too I know well they do that in
like they have a burger place down in
Hollywood that has alcohol milkshakes
really yeah it's on some tent yeah
called Red Robin now have [ __ ]
milkshakes for years really the Coco
Loco when I was in college I drank coco
loco's every night I went from one
[ __ ] 85 to 210 yeah I kept saying
what swelling me up the [ __ ] in my
gorilla climb said you drink ten coco
loco's that night sure you're gonna [ __ ]
that milk milk Kahlua everything with
sugar guys and I do a couple bumps of
[ __ ] blows
the blow for 20 years that is not guilty
but did that keep your weight down get
your kid could you maintain weight on
the blow listen the fattest people I've
seen the biggest cocaine saloons I think
I don't know what the [ __ ] they would
like bottom you're right let's look at
grass birds that I think the smoke and
the sweat and jumping up and down
chasing people burns a lot of fat when
you do crack when you do blow when
you're trying to get your dick sucked
you know you you're an evil [ __ ] it's
amazing it's amazing the only thing I
ever really saw good about about cocaine
was it was in the 80s it was amazing
[ __ ] bait oh my god you had to coke you
had the [ __ ] oh my god oh you have to
do is come out of a bathroom look
everybody look at you it was like that
people don't remember you know it's just
I tried to describe it to people that
the cocaine marketing was the most
brilliant marketing in the world because
for years we paid nickel bags heroin was
$3 reefer was whatever hits the acid
with $3 awesome these Spanish people
that were five foot six showed up but
this white magical pilot that they
wanted a hundred a grand foot that's it
nobody sold half a grams nobody saw
nothing in 1970 it was grams of blow 400
I was a [ __ ] grant and as soon as
people bought that it wasn't about the
drunk it was about the raisin class you
were somebody else that's how they sold
cocaine it's like buying a bottle of Dom
periodic that's it that you're exactly
right and that's all about was the
marketing scheme for cocaine forget
about getting on we're gonna make you
that person you never been good with
celebrities when you come out and go
Aspen the baby call was you know with
Pepco you got a razor blade you know
like this
I lived in Aspen for two years from 83
to 85 most people will not believe at
this time and I will stated was an aspen
colorado from 1982 to 85 was the cocaine
capital of the united states people no
joy but it was in Miami listen to me go
to your Wikipedia check it out they were
blown [ __ ] Puerto Ricans up in Aspen
Colorado
yeah it goes with the Peter white it was
a great place to live it was a great
question you know the other place and
people don't know lake tahoe tremendous
it was a major drug place because if you
got if you got real money and the drug
dealers had real money why not live in
Aspen or like Tom but you get what are
you living the [ __ ] Albuquerque we
can live with with in the hottest place
that's gotta run with the Jews tell them
exactly everyone so why you gotta have a
Jew somewhere exact if you're gonna run
with money somewhere 20 feet there's
gotta be a [ __ ] Jew is a good luck
[ __ ] hey where's Tim Tony Bennett
break this [ __ ] how did how did
the Jews let the Colombians get the
cocaine deal the Jews are a class act I
don't need that oh they got proof okay
you know every time you [ __ ] with the
joy as they'll show you the cross I
wanna be rich
oh [ __ ] ha ha ha ha the bigger the
pieces are you kidding me away strap it
on by the [ __ ] streets go get a
cocktail come back
tell mama you want to look a little
[ __ ] monkey with him but the man step
is half making it happen I'm gonna start
calling [ __ ] mostly I'm all a.m. I know
and if you're in France is to monk wah
we're gonna give a little taste of monk
wah de Beauvoir they look at you like
what the [ __ ] you feel Ava so uh what is
your age I'm 23
yeah well look have you decided to do
this well I'm still a rookie I've been
working six months now so it's very
interesting because when I live in asked
I had just heard 20 wood and I remember
going to the bars at night you know the
Paragon was old by Jimmy Buffett at the
time ah
the tower was all by John Denver the
I'll never forget walking down the
street you're too young to remember this
but Denis I remember walking down the
street one day and seen ten women walk
right by me we've been running and
taking their heels off hey come back and
looking to go what the [ __ ] is going on
they go with chasing Don Johnson yeah
this is what Don Johnson was being
chased by women on the [ __ ] Street
it's Don John exactly Miami Vice Oh
though they were those crazy shirts and
fought crime right that was yes in a
white Ferrari test analyzes Testarossa
eye when John Denver was playing at
Harrah's I went up in his jet and
watched the Eclipse which happens like
every whatever eight hundred years or 50
years whatever this eclipse in in at
50,000 feet in John's jet it was
phenomenal that's amazing it was amazing
to see an eclipse 50,000 feet in the air
in a jet yeah 23 so i'ma go walking
around Aspen gold if I was a young woman
right
today cuz I was attractive and hey I
will become a prostitute at that aids I
said even if I do it for four years in
charge these [ __ ] wall around mm
apart at the end of four years I could
buy a house I could buy I'm like Tony
Montana 84 but but able to buy a house a
golf course and get 25 years old and
it's like you start all over
nobody [ __ ] the way you've been for
five years living in Michigan I don't
[ __ ] know that's what with the girls
that's what the world knows it's you
have to like she she doesn't come from a
long line of adora families that's not
her name okay it's a name how'd you get
that name uh well there's this the band
the Smashing Pumpkins they have a song
called Ava door and I love that song
it's my dad's favorite band and I love
it cuz it I'm adorable but without the
ball this is that is isn't that great so
you're right
she'll go on and be a doctor and landed
doing research there's a [ __ ] save the
world either the title gives a [ __ ] we
both I'm 51 it's amazing the things I
did I thought it was the world I was 27
and it doesn't change who the little man
may be Who I am
a man is as old as the girl he sleeps
with so I'm 23 and yeah beautiful the
thing about you is I can see your
happiness in your face you're sincerely
happy guy you opened my eyes tonight
Rafa was like I said I was so turned off
when I was 17 I never had use of it
again
that's a terrible experience I've got to
get you up there with or without your
wife by the way whether your party or
not you just need to get up there and be
around the girls because there's nothing
more stimulating than and being around
20 30 40 girls and big hair and makeup
and having fun and laughing and giggling
whether you're drinking and smoking a
cigar it it's a last place in America
you can drink 24 hours a day you can
smoke cigars 24 hours a day and you get
laid 24 hours day there's nothing like
it in America
it's chair I got a taster alter adults
so I get i fluid there's event arena
I took the 9:45 American Airlines gets
you in Torino 11:05 with 10 minutes
early we Coast I get my luggage the guy
picks me up I get to the hotel I check
to the room I turned the TV on what's on
[ __ ] HBO that night I'm sitting there
watching if you guys having a great time
but then no I'm just saying this is ER
there's a little a little person girl
Oh Bridget that's Bridget yeah this is
real Bridget yeah Bridget's real Hey so
I can go up there [ __ ] Bridget well
she's not there right now but yeah we do
have meal replacement little one let's
have one of their so listen oh I got to
jeez I want to take Bridges cousin over
here just [ __ ] fling her around the
room but then [ __ ] was you know at the
end of this whole thing was got like a
[ __ ] up collarbone I'll pay for the
hospital bills I got sag insurance
whatever because nobody has ever like
sucked the [ __ ] of a [ __ ] the flayed
I would love it like why not leave what
was my stop the placements you can't
replace me a little bit Minh sure you
can we were right we were out it well
but it's like kids have them like you
only have the one that said she doesn't
have like a cover no we've had we've had
other ones but this she's a famous most
heinous one so what the faces out there
one night we're in a casino in a steak
house and I'm with Air Force Amy they
loaded the legend
and a girl named Sheila Fox a beautiful
porn girl that only did a few movies but
she was maybe maybe one of the top two
or three most beautiful girls Evers and
so we're all there and so they had a
vegetable tray now the vegetable tray
had this little starter a little
appetizer and so China love the
pepperoncinis okay and it's so bridges
have all these hot well they're a little
tangy oh I wouldn't consider a
pepperoncini hot they're just hanging
right and she's so Bridgette takes a
bite out of one her our eyes spin around
or hit their head starts freaking out
she wrote she grabs a glass of water
slams it down she runs out of this
restaurant full blast this is a little
person running 100 mile an hour runs all
through the casino back around around
the tables and here she comes back into
the restaurant with two security guys at
the casino manager following her and
she's just out the table one it just the
casino matters Dennis everything okay as
high as you see a pepper Cheney was a
little hot for or what and that was that
was Bridget I don't know daddy did you
ever sleep with Bridget I did not yeah
and I I tell I was afraid to and I told
her one I very sincere listen look
thought she had a crush on you dude
really let me knows I'm there you gotta
be I I don't know but she the bottom
line is I said look I'm six-three you're
three foot ten
if I [ __ ] you and it's the best I ever
had
you and I are going to look stupid
together hauling around the rest of your
life okay you need to find since like
five five and it's it's symmetrical
it'll look like it should and she ended
up at doing that and having a kid and
all that but it's like I wouldn't take a
chance what if you what if I party with
her it was the best I ever had
we just look ridiculous together I have
to talk to she's she's short I'm tall
look silly
he'd care it was a comedian at the
Comedy Store I can't remember what her
name was very funny from Canada I think
she was she ended up marrying a guy and
then she got the school and he come up
with her with the school what's her name
Lee she's come to the comedy store no no
have you about eight years ago she got
hit by a [ __ ] sunset oh my god live
in the scooter and the [ __ ] as I was
saying it his ability to put her in the
scooter he got into school because her
hip was bad or something you know she
had the big hips she was very funny
better in Canada she was very sweet I
always spoke to her we were all mutual
friend to another friend she got hit in
the scooter I don't forget the call
saying well I do the benefit of
something yeah somebody close they
whacked her not me yeah she's lived no
she's a lot I haven't seen in a while
open she's still around but I haven't
seen a woman it's [ __ ] up store a lien
to my brother Lou it's a [ __ ] the
[ __ ] car is the respect news oh so
she was a little person - yes he was a
little more so oh they are hip because
they do have problems right so now she's
in a scooter and they whack her in the
scooter they whacked but her husband was
six foot one nice guy glasses yeah
educated had a job you know it wasn't
like some [ __ ] guy looking for a head
now let me just
little person got a jack I don't [ __ ]
know what they do anyone know famous
little person she's five three famous is
[ __ ] Savage she's bad acid you know
wow it must be hardest to do your show
with an erection no I'm okay I respect I
like I've been angling the boobs towards
Anderson so explain what happened I know
what I would never want to do that day
but I showed my dick and my nutsack is
that psychological portrayed say showing
it I'm not another sailor for you gonna
be steaming like I'm stimulated oh she's
beautiful she's flawless she just she's
beauty and she does [ __ ] effect she
could be Cuban she got that yeah yeah
that's why I asked her he did ask let me
ask you to savor I won't point your life
after a guy [ __ ] had a caramel area
that you said you know what I'm gonna do
this for like the last boy forget you
just murder him like he just [ __ ]
woke up with day was I spent it and
either you know what I got good [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] Burger King gonna go solve
this crime [ __ ] monkey right now and
she gone right over is that how it
happened I've been tellin ya you're very
good at what you did you're very
beautiful actually a little bit like
it's who do you say it um when I went to
Boston you know Boston is kind of the
land of white girls and of course there
aren't you know different people there
but I'd realize that every boyfriend I'd
ever had and anybody who I'd mess around
with they tell me that they started you
know [ __ ] me because they were
interested like they were intrigued by
you know this girl is tan she looks
different don't it out and then I would
blow their mind and they told me that
they'd never be able to sleep with a
white girl again then after being with
me really yeah I've heard that for maybe
two or three days every your skin is
amazing beautiful it's an amazing color
and the texture and it melts in your
mouth I might add see you every woman
all your which is a
throwing heat like this and she is not
all of them we got a couple of them that
I wouldn't sleep with but the majority
of them are very attractive girls and
but do you know the beauty is if the
eyes are the color my size like with Ava
let me tell you some Avis beauty is so
radiant right now that if I bet a lot of
guys who just want to sit next to you
give you a couple yards things mm-hmm
because I think that you know it's
really weird I'm buried and I got the
[ __ ] kid when you go home you know
talk about nothing else but the [ __ ]
kid for three hours and I bet that it's
the truth you know it's a different time
warp whatever
I'm very happy for my wife I love the
child but sometimes the guys driving
home either like tonight I want to [ __ ]
somebody in the [ __ ] in like that's
it we get home and and also they just
bombard you with the kid [ __ ] or
something else and your hard-on goes
into your [ __ ] because then I you got
a [ __ ] wait till tool to get a
hard-on again to think about and I can
see guys as a relief go to see Ava and
it's not once a week but if they do
something it's more than a sexual
release it's a mental reason to release
you guys see it I see it it's hard it's
hard for a guy to be arguing over a
credit-card bill with with a girl
wouldn't bought two personnel boots for
$5,000 and then say hey would you mind
blowing me I mean there's so many
pressures of a family and having kids
and like you like it's not like wifey
can can you come come home and and be
all hot and you never close on drinking
or Bhalla bottle of wine and being all
sexy you got to take care of this baby
and so it adds another dimension to it
and guys can get away from that world
and step into our world and for a little
while have a great time and go back home
and nobody knows
we knows the difference and so I would I
I think a man that's married
we keep marriages together oh it's so
true yeah so true I mean we have we have
a client's been coming in for years now
and he'll come in every few months every
you know whatever and he doesn't even
like to like we were saying before have
sex with us he just wants to he wants to
chat he wants to watch two girls play
with each other you know and he has I
think five children his marriage is you
know 4050 years strong just has 20
grandkids you know and he just he enjoys
being generous with us girls and he goes
back to his life you know away from the
bunny ranch and is a great father and a
great husband why I did that
because before I bought the red could go
and go back for you before I bought the
ranch I was in a relationship for six
years it was it was a gratis course and
a very nice girl loved her to death but
it ran its course so so I was doing a
deal in Florida with Swiss Airlines in
Sea World
so I would fly back to Torino so there's
two flights one of them got in in about
5:30 and the other one got it at 10
o'clock so I would always tell her I'm
taking the one where I arrive at 10
o'clock but I get there 5:30 I go out to
the ranch I drink a cup of coffee I bang
Banga girl and sit around and just laugh
and giggle and talk to the girls and get
all the pressures in my head and I'd go
home my house in Tahoe and crawled in
with her and I was so thrilled to see
her it actually kept that thing going
for another year and the relationship
was really over with and I know that I
know clients are in there of that same
thing you don't want to give up the
relationship they don't give up their
kids but they but they have to have an
outside stimulation whether it be just
verbal stimulation or
or sexual now how did the HBO series
come about you know I I wanted I thought
I want to have a TV show
there wasn't any reality shows 13 years
ago the only thing was out there was was
real world yeah and so I thought you
know I wanted I want to show the world
what this place is because the Nevada
law does not let me buy any television
radio or newsprint can advertise a
brothel so I thought how can I get the
world to know that we're here I came up
with this idea and I went to Showtime
and I said here's what I want to do and
they loved it and they said you know
what we want to do it but we want to do
a scripted version because the money is
in syndication and we want to do
scripted version or shoot all the
exterior x' we'll build a set
we'll build a bunny ranch in in in
hollywood and you tell us all the
stories and the girls that tell us the
stories and then our actors will live it
out and like know what's going to make
it work is the fact that they can
actually come visit these girls and
visit these place and they'll lock on to
one of the girls and follow her and
that's what's going to make it work so
they said nope we wanna do a syndication
so I I went to HBO
because HBO's like the supermodel that
never gets [ __ ] nobody's got the balls
to go to talk to her when she's horny as
can be and because everybody puts her up
on this platform way that's HBO HBO HBO
is 800-pound gorillas there's a badass
and so I went to them and we're in this
meeting and they said Dennis you've been
everywhere we've seen you on 20/20 we
did what what can we do different it is
I don't know and this well what do you
like about HBO I said you know I'd be
honest with you
the one thing I ever watches two taxicab
confession and and Sheila Nevins says
Pingo can we cam a room for two weeks
because Nevada is a one-party state
so like right now we're sitting in this
room if everybody has to know we're
being filmed or you go to jail in Nevada
and New York or one party states so as
long as one party knows if one party in
this room
knows it's being filmed it's okay so I
said yeah we'll try it and we'll just
film the negotiations and picking that
girl how to line up and and it was a
smash smash hit highest-rated
non-fiction show HBO had ever done the
ratings were enormous I mean if you if
if you weren't talk if you didn't see
the show you had nothing to talk about
around the water cooler the next day I
mean Saturday Night Live ripped on it
and as you know you want to be part of
Kult America Saturday Night Live rips on
you guess what you made it and and so I
mean that that's how it all came about
and then we only did that for two weeks
one time and that started the show and
then it was people latching on to the
different girls the air force Amy Sunset
Thomas tailors Madame Suzette my life
I'm with this girl and I break up with
her and I do this me me have the
discipline somebody or having a sales
meeting and it's just I open the doors
to the cathouse and people love coming
in and they and they still do 13 years
later
I mean Sam Simon when I was on the show
a few months ago so Tess you know that
the only show on television it's been on
longer than yours is The Simpsons
he's the co-founder of The Simpsons and
I'm like really yep absolutely
so it's been a long time and it just
never gets old it gets like her story's
amazing I'm here and I mean she she's so
non-typical because what happens is the
right wing in the media they look at a
prostitute and and they're right 90% of
the time under age ethnic shortswords
street corner crack pipe and a pimp down
the street taking the money until you
legalize it and then when you make it
legal then you get girls like Ava
beautiful comes from a nice family she's
got alternatives she's not desperate
she's got a
reg ocation and and she brings a lot to
the table so people are shocked because
they're like wow that's like the chick I
wish the next door to me you know
instead of that skanky little [ __ ] that
goes next door to us and so they see our
world and they're curious about it and
they want to step into it and a
percentage of them come there and the
the reason the show so popular is
because the girls are attainable like
when you watch Hefner show and I highly
respect you you have never what he
brought to America but nobody's going to
[ __ ] his girls I mean it's just not it's
not going to happen okay so you don't
have the fantasy of a bangin those ghost
girls of those three girls his old
ladies because it's not going to happen
so heap in our show they see a girl say
you know what I like her I can be with
her I'm attracted her so so it
stimulates you even more and other
reality shows don't have that like like
I like the fishing boat guys okay if I
sketch or where the hell it is but guess
what I'm never going to go ride that
boat but I'd like to show okay and so it
could be another show that's the same
way that has that that same element is
upon stars
people people go to Vegas it's a tourist
attraction in Las Vegas now people want
to go to pawn stars just walk through
the store and feel like you know they
they see the guys behind the counter and
and it's the same way the money what
look at all the tourists that come in
there oh it's so true I mean you get a
whole cup Torito for that oh oh yeah
people plant they watch the show and
then go [ __ ] it they go online whatever
the yellow pay whatever they need to do
you got the blue haired old ladies
coming in there buying shot glasses
family reunions Oh tour buses come
through and they'll stop what
yeah we're gonna start with I just I
just got ordained and I've got my
licensing from the state of Nevada and
I'm going to do this and that came from
that Grizzly Adams Grizzly Adams and
integrity did a wedding there I thought
well I can do this and I know Dan very
well and so I'm going to come up with
some whole spiel who gives this but it's
like he gives who sells this and we
don't give anything okay and I'm gonna
do my whole what do you think so people
can come there they can have a bachelor
party a bachelorette party and they and
they get married the next day right
there at the ranch and have their
honeymoon I've had many honeymoon
parties of two cup a couple thousand and
you know they want part of me to be part
of their honeymoon experience no that's
the way to start a relationship you
start a wedding of a marriage like that
with another chick in your bed you're
gonna be with that girl one of the
hottest parties I've ever had for sure
hands-down was the couple's honeymoon
party I did it was so hot thank you
definitely have a visit you you have an
open invitation big favor for me what's
up Lee is when I tell you is he lived in
Boston real quickly with the home fast
he's a very nice boy
but we have a running gag game of the
show and that well I always know we want
to over the phone in his mouth oh no he
doesn't have the balls to ask his
girlfriend look he's never licked an
[ __ ] he's looked at one when he eats
his girlfriend's [ __ ] but he's never
late going to whatever so we wanted to
get Lee on pay-per-view
or maybe on the show to have a girl fart
of his mouth because I think that's the
next level of entertainment this country
well it's going to see women front your
[ __ ] face we can strap him down to if
I don't know leaves a volatile easy
you know we don't want the heat we don't
want to [ __ ] for three or four days just
feed me the beans hot dogs okay and you
know what we had the opportunity but we
lost it because we went to Barney's
Beanery and had a chili dog but we
shared it I'm running out for my
restaurant
he's on class somebody read response let
me check it out hot dog Isis and trying
to get the best everybody's got a
different opinion well it's good so we
shared it if she would've ate that big
chili dog we could have done it tonight
I'm so I screwed up oh my god I'm gonna
say anything in my arm
save me a lot activation here because
I'm look I look at hot dogs is something
different okay when I came from Cuba as
a young man there was nothing boy one of
the world to be an American
I grew up on the Dick Van Dyke Show dog
you know Jake van Dyken
and a hot dog was superb so I went as a
young man it surged the better the hot
dog the better American happy that was
my first 10 years of this country
I [ __ ] love hot dogs and I'm still to
this day I'm still a sad bright guy I'm
still a sad bright guy and I hope most
recently a buddy of mine put an ad on he
was selling his hot dog truck and there
was nothing in the world I would want to
be do more and to buy a hot dog I want
to buy it it's still around I even
called him 25 grand flat his name is
Bobby bender 25 great he's had the
business in front of shop right in front
of the pool hall and movie theater for
the last 28 years but he can't do it no
more because it's too much of a hall fan
from South Jersey so he put on Facebook
like Walt listen what how much you
charging is over 25 grand everything the
onions and chili I got everything the
car the business you could move into the
cart in front of the hotdogs Blake out
you know keep it existed there mm-hmm
but I have a hotdog cart
oh my god I love it but I would like to
separate I'm a Sabra guy I like to
there's a place real door steamed both I
love about there's a place in Boulder
you know Chicago makes a tremendous
[ __ ] unbelievable unbelievable with
the pickles [ __ ] tremendous you know
don't get mad and don't mean you don't
stick up one of these [ __ ] jerk walls
look New York listen before I was
swearing me I did The Longest Yard I was
for eight [ __ ] teen okay then that
ain't no Wendy's at mcdonnell's but I
tell you what makes a nice dog did he
the Cuban and whole dopes up a dog with
a [ __ ] Savage it's all what you put
on what up what you put on it
a Cuban will cut the dog fry with the
onions in the frying pan then put
mustard as they cook it moving around
really and then put it on the [ __ ]
but tremendous but then you got a place
like Scooby's in Hollywood that's you go
in there there's a problem that they
done for the hot dogs in this country
they reinvented it for no [ __ ] reason
listen I'll go eat your hot dog but yet
when I walk to the car and I'm not cheap
when I walk to the car and say wait a
second I just got three hot dogs
another fries $22 - Hollywood that's
what it is we're gonna scoop you thing
at the best lemonade given that but
you're right now I was I was in Chicago
and checking the places out it's a cargo
docks okay so I went to poor Tio's I may
have with it yeah it run apart okay and
and that's right and for sale but I had
Zack what tools were hired the whole
chain to sail again - all billion
dollars Wow
billion dollars Lea [ __ ] steak place
up kind of burger place going to play go
naughty bugger is Italian salad sandwich
well you should go the hot beef with the
sausage god damn that's the night damn
we where did you go is what Paul's mom
makes the the Mexican the medley do
fried bacon around my mother right it's
oh my and then they put made mini the
street dogs would be good the prom with
the street dogs is they use a shitty hot
dog exactly if they use the quality hot
dog with the bacon yeah say thank you
got a [ __ ] Sabra a Vienna of Vienna
Nathan's a day things now we're cooking
with gas
ok some sprouts about three years ago
nobody knew about this rounds right here
and Sherman Oaks
they have a special Florence to
Nathan's in a soda for $2 nobody [ __ ]
know but I was the only Jew that went in
there at all there was Jews walking
around he don't even stop for a hotdog
I'm a dairy [ __ ] - for two dollars
until I'm blonde so I go to poor Tio's
and and I had this our PR person with me
so we got the big Italian beef
sandwiches with all the peppers on and
extra sauce and we cut we shared it and
then we got a hot dog and the hot dog
you know what they use they they steam
them and they use an Oscar Mayer hot dog
it's the last hot dog I would think as
I've you as a quality hot dog not bad
and you know it was delicious delicious
what you put on it but see I like it I
think for my restaurant I want fried I
want to split down the middle I like
them grill - but give them options you
grill it pull oh yeah
put it back toaster bunt nothing pisses
me off when they give me a cold you
gotta test my mouth and I'm not talking
about sit there just put it over the
thing why are you staring and talking to
me about did you see the game last night
look at that girl's ass it's a magic
[ __ ] trick it's a magic trick hate
the [ __ ] but you [ __ ] they give
you this cold [ __ ] bug with a hot dog
and it grows your intestines on the buns
are always hotted up anyways Oh funny
railing always has hot bun [ __ ] buns
in the world I love you [ __ ] let
me give a shot to these sponsors here
okay who are they because I want to
support let me give a shot to these
people watch the show they're gonna be
fans of yours Jeffrey wheeler Henryville
Itoro happy birthday
was he pranks happy birthday Joe rook I
love you sexy [ __ ] Ben Christie Mike
Davidson for the UK and listen to this
thing Armando Salgado he's got about ten
cousins on that [ __ ] bus coming up
[ __ ] got most of all Papa and
fried [ __ ] is that it is that Anita wad
I Nino I need a wand right there uh uh
yeah I think so she likes to watch the
show I need a wad
first off some day I'll hook you up with
it or bring it on it okay honor this the
next level is not a supplement that a
[ __ ] future what does it do for you
Alan has a thing called alpha brain it's
like giving your mind cocaine without
the habit and it makes you very aware it
makes you very your dreams become more
vivid you become very clear alpha brain
is a great product but they also got
into the protein product they use head
protein it's a cleaner protein they also
have a product called Nero's shroom -
shroom tech is one of my favorites
because it gives you they use psilocybin
[ __ ] mushrooms I'm saying it right
they use mushrooms and they increase
your [ __ ] oxygen intake the
tremendous they have a shrewd tech
before you get on a flight so you push
your beaut system I don't know you don't
drink that they have it before you work
out can you get some more you don't get
one nearest their sounds great so you
got a hot it calm it sold by a friend of
mine elaborate tremendous he sends me
product I take up myself I like I said I
love I want the bunny ranch to be the
international Test Center for this so
[ __ ]
tremendous we're gonna hook on it up
with you so gonna heinens.com impress
Church in the [ __ ] box just like that
BAM
ch you are CH in case you got up
something C in spelling put it in there
get 10% off and sign up for the on it
program where they send it right to you
how stay on it a month that's what you
got to do you got to get a program where
we just mail a piece of [ __ ] ass to
your house of the first of the bun I
think up in they sook aa week they do
some [ __ ] head sides and then go
right back the [ __ ] the bunny ranch I
can see that the UPS driver Ava Ava in a
big box oh my god
wrapped up with roses with a [ __ ]
chocolate ice cream but I little with a
return label yeah
they come right back to be back in no I
don't strand me in the middle of nowhere
Nunnally never come back I get you sir
what are the sponsor you got we got
HuluPlus calm oh you know what not April
they tell you about Hulu [ __ ] use
Hulu oh yeah we'd be like the hookers
get Hulu cool because it works they
catch up on all that and see flows are
up who lose listen if you're a real
hooker after eight o'clock you do it
things
okay you ain't got time to sit down
watch Milan family and say look how cute
the [ __ ] gay guy is you're on all
fours you got a guy by the [ __ ] deck
who's moaning did you hear that [ __ ] I
was on my hallucinating I got a saw I
heard it - you heard it - something's
melted somebody's getting [ __ ] in the
building right now see wherever you are
somebody's getting picked up like 20
feet away I love it that's the type of
energy you forget Hulu Plus a tremendous
all right I think Hulu is the best thing
going on Google+ as these program watch
Hulu anywhere anytime and any devices
iPhones iPads is the beauty $7.99 a
month 7.99 up what's that [ __ ] 96
dollars a year to get unlimited
programming they always get exclusively
they get the simpsons location September
they gotta get the citizens go to Hulu
Plus compress Joey in the Box get two
weeks for free 790 listen some people if
you go to a commercial Meuse it at home
tonight check it off you're gonna watch
it for $7.99 a month great that's great
I give you two weeks on the arm for free
talk to my man Dennis hop see if you can
walk in the bunny rec to say give me two
weeks of a [ __ ] [ __ ] for free then
I decide if I get out and then ain't got
a [ __ ] happen Hulu does it because
we're with Hulu who's with us we're with
them they're with us okay what you can't
go your website find all this yeah it
was not you okay but what we do is not
then tortillas done and I got bad as out
all over the same thing Dollar Shave
Club is a great wolfy listen always hear
some shaving the shaving some poon
assist remove the [ __ ] shape well you
got to do some special you know Filipino
well [ __ ] the Brigid juice rubber
Linehan so those are only people that
would shave your [ __ ] and Filipinos
right or wrong what speaking Jews binge
juice together didn't they use pictures
for everything with your Filipino
they've David magicians they do
everything they [ __ ]
rub them what one time
whatever we are the stirred show in this
girl had a big party and this is like oh
is $20,000 some house you can buy a
Filipino family for that for 20 G's no
show up [ __ ] good anyway listen you
got to go to the supermarket gotta go
ever stand on line together by those
raises if you don't buy the right razors
it gives you when you're eating [ __ ]
you can see all the stubble you know I
do know your stubble
my reason burn what do you want to do is
this that you got to pay 20 30 bucks for
a raise and it comes with a flashlight a
hood a stereo and iPad you don't need
that you need two blades you need some
aloe of that [ __ ] monkey
what Dollar Shave Club is this they mail
the [ __ ] pee on state a dollar a month
six dollars a month or $30 a month you
go online you sign up they also have one
wipe Charlies you don't know what my
charlie is no you wipe your little
Buffalo in or your help it really smells
like peppermint pattie it's Christmas
every [ __ ] mean you know it smells
like Santa Claus and wife suck it dick
it's happening patty
well well thank God they got everything
of the shave butter I got the shea
butter be tremendous shadow that's
really the razors are [ __ ] tremendous
okay the razors come to your door and
the first of the month you get an email
like on the 29th they tell your razors
around the way what package you want to
go to is what you want to go to the
dollar package you get a single blade
that's great to the [ __ ] blade they
give you the hammer if you can hit
somebody as a weapon I take them on the
road I shave with them that's why I cut
my [ __ ] face number two they that's a
$6 plan they give you two blades
right then you got the [ __ ] $9 plan
where they give you two blades and hallo
and then they send them right to your
mail you'd only go online you don't
gotta get one of those blades last you
for the a week or three weeks
you're really reusable that's not good
and I'm not even [ __ ] you're not
because they're my sponsor I use this
myself
Hulu Plus my wife uses I use con it I
don't [ __ ] around
right here look Kitty what if I go to
Dollar Shave Club
Press Church in the box and get two
weeks for free $7.99 a month that's
that's who doesn't Joey that's Joey
we'll make up your [ __ ] mind why you
confused now Hulu Plus is Joe it is
mixed Hulu Plus is what Joey
alright and Dollar Shave Club is
cheering to make up your [ __ ] mind
you got me all confused you know I ate
an edible oh alright now I want to walk
up my new sponsor hit ecigs calm whether
you want to cigar whether you want to
[ __ ] a cigarette don't get you off
the cigarettes I say you want to quit
smoking boom you have a 24 milligram to
get the party started
if you're a week ago doing a sixteen
after another week you go to eight after
another week boob you smoking a
cigarette
with no 19 diggity Thank You Lee it's
good to have you up my quality its
stuttering [ __ ] now you get this
right here hit e-cigs you know why I
like it better tasty and they last night
we were puffing on this to go on nightly
not tremendous or what tell me and I
feel like going up for the bunny ranch
right now smoking a cigar and blowing it
some chicks [ __ ] face with you were
there right there like Don Corleone II
know you would never be amazing don't
[ __ ] around I've watched you guys smoke
these all night long I long jumper yeah
and your dear loving it
I like the cigarette one but I also like
this cigar is perfect you go to Vegas I
got a bunny ranch nobody's feelings
gonna hurt hey chubby get the [ __ ] out
of here with that cigar you're never
gonna hear that [ __ ] I love these things
no but you are believer this thing know
what you wouldn't you enjoyed having a
nice hot chick below you while you're
smoking your isang cigar I want to do a
lot of things that there's no one that's
no Creed I want to pick her up and eat
her ass and finger
Jim you're a normal guy he's so poor oh
I love all those were my world because I
come in a minute and a half two minutes
that that chick destroyed my [ __ ]
[ __ ] machine we need to come back for
that his girl I was a dry humping
machine
I used to dry hump [ __ ] till they
could walk home after their fathers to
come together I was a dry humping
[ __ ] I'd get that [ __ ] dick
and pilot to that [ __ ] lease trip he
always got that Lee Jean strip they were
like oh yeah in the seventies girl Louis
that's it then those leaves had that
strip you dried up the lead don't forget
I get excited just thinking about know
what the [ __ ] we go to hit he sings calm
right now today these are my favorite
out there that better-tasting their last
one with the cigarettes they got a
[ __ ] deal like 12,000 [ __ ] puffs
you know big pumps is that you'll be
puffing I think one Pat one one little
dip is equal to four packs of cigarettes
these guys will see you're going to Hulu
and sitting around smoking you're eating
all night long all mine like a doctor
yeah after you shave I'll do you shave
of course you guys I suppose after you
shave your nutsack you save somebody's
ma there's a trick to saving you a nut
sack and so this this saver would be the
ideal thing telling you right now
heavy sinks calm go to the box and press
one Joey's chicks Joey's church jo e ' I
said what nullify all right whatever CH
you are CH Joey's Church go there right
now
let me get 20% of anything and last week
never given away free cigars and Freesat
thing you got one for like a thousand
yeah yarmulke cigar
what's all this gonna cost it could cost
$7.99 for who $7.99 and it's gonna cost
me a buck a month for the shave right
yeah we're gonna go up with great okay
six six bucks bro so now I'm in this 14
bucks right okay in an e-cig what's that
gonna suck garden fortunately what are
your four dollars off that be used for
Six Sigma free shipping but every ship
forever
hmm so you're like $34 you got only
those lefties at night yeah I got a
puffball up Dale again moto Rica no
puppies at night no Porto Ricans
yeah gonna walk the hang our drinking
through a funny [ __ ] we're
trying to have a good [ __ ] time it's
Monday night and I'm happy you came down
I had a great drops image honest I had
such a good time all of you thank you
thank you for smoking with me a little
high a little wee hey III you know I was
gonna start to show it out you guys say
it I'm the only one who's gonna make
sense to that because these two are so
[ __ ] high but you guys did good you
guys maintained were functioning I
functional I'm amazing and I ate like a
s'more I have needed edible sister
podcast but my myself I was the Icehouse
and they got this blue swore that they
dip it and THC butter let he said try it
kids is one of those I brought you that
those things are tremendous able to
enjoy those the Green Hornet's it's cute
it looks like a little Jolly Ranchers
yeah they taste tremendous I think we
only ate a half of it yet she's nothing
better let me tell what happened [ __ ]
edibles away left of the car and it
melted last week I took a home unplug
the freezer I came back me at least look
at how high we oh my god what hope I see
the Jewish Apple did you know these do
these guys that give you these edibles
that do they advertise on your show no
relation what does I want it boy I sure
though that you know what they used to
we used to do something when we get free
edibles I think a switch morning hmm
they switch that marketing around but
they're good well then we should
[ __ ] them then until they come
back out there okay Dennis it was a
[ __ ] pleasure Ava I love you all bye
how you're beautiful I wish you luck in
your medical career the map you did this
because you have the balls to take the
world by the [ __ ] balls you guys you
guys are fun and I can't wait to get you
up there there's got to come
yep Michael I'm Colin way to blow up
blow it up then only to book a day I'm
gonna hold you to it
right now my birthday my birthday party
is September 13th a private party okay
and a owner of the Lakers and I have a
joint birthday party for 18 years
everybody you ever wanted to be done
Celebrity Rehab will be there
okay and it's a fun party there'll be
200 girls there and it's a perfect time
it's a party you can bring your wife to
if you wanted to or if you just want to
do a little eat
Oh Machado he could be munching on a
budget September 13 Lee I'm open that
day [ __ ] you're open to I don't
want to hear that you gonna something
fun would you go tell me where you went
last money where tell me what you want
to do that's right oh my girlfriend what
we did a cooking class a crepe class so
I spider-man you ate you ate the crate
was try like that creeps are great
I'm sure they bonded it took up some
pathetic fuck-ups I'm gonna give I'm
gonna get Joey set up with the bunny
buffet you know that's for girls all
laying on the bed that you get together
let's get her on the phone I'd love to
have it's a reputable drug you start on
one he starts you it's a Neapolitan okay
and then you start off with a blonde and
then you go to the redhead okay and then
you you go to the brunette that's the
Neapolitan and then we throw in an extra
scoop of chocolate for the fourth girl
that's the same present a tad too tall
Jones gave Hollywood Henderson for his
28th birthday with a with Dallas Cowboys
really Wow and you can you can relive
that experience [ __ ] yeah
the fact I got invited tomorrow to go to
the Raider cowboy game my baby gets
carsick they do right here
Thousand Oaks you know excellent I'll
get rock star that's what their training
camp is what I'll say they going up
there they have passes that they have a
place for the children to play
I would
cancelled everything you're coming to my
birthday party I Love You Man flying up
here and we're gonna have so what's the
website they go Johnny rich calm find us
on online shopping in the world we make
Amazon look like nothing we when you got
hot chicks you got it all at bunny ranch
calm and watch our HBO show set your
TiVo we could it's called taeho in our
world and in its on hooker box office
cathouse hooker box that's what HBO a
really fine guys I know because I'm on
them Emma tell you because you're a New
Yorker and East Coast got the real
ending to the Sopranos now meadow first
those two years okay and you're going to
find out why it took two years to get
that last show meadow runs into the
restaurant remember and Tony his wife
earned there eaten have dinner and
meadow runs in and what it went black
but what you didn't hear because they
cut it out is meadow says dad mom I got
accepted at the bunnyranch after two
years that's why it went black
you like that [ __ ] yeah I love you
I love you guys thank you for watching
thank you the Dennis thank you again a
view or a trip to paradise whatever
flying Jew who's better you know buddy
at my man over here from Newark in the
house Disney I love dear do you any
shows well I got nothing I'm component
Paducah being doing a show Friday night
at a coffee shop Paducah and my family
is reunion I don't live in a coffee shop
No beside that I'm home but I would
serger than 26 so I'm whole Clementi
good luck come on what are they doing to
it after scopic malicious arthritis I'll
beep in the pool where the stitches come
out I'll be [ __ ] the rehab is the
trick the rehab is the hope at war and I
didn't do a good job on that I need to
do more good night we love you stay
black [ __ ] head it weak oh my
goodness now that the show is over don't
forget to sign up for your free trial of
Hulu Plus Hulu Plus lets you binge on
thousands of it shows anytime anywhere
on your TV PC smartphone or tablet
support this podcasting is an extended
free trial of Hulu Plus when you go to
Hulu Plus calm so we or go to Joey Diaz
net and click on the Hulu Plus Banner
don't forget to sign up for dogster.com
get high-quality razors sent to your
door every month for a fraction of what
you pay at retail now go dogs shave club
calm /search or just go to Joey Diaz net
and click on the Dollar Shave Club
Boehner shows also sponsored by on Comm
go there for alpha brain new moon swim
tech meeting sport use code word Church
to get 10% off and going to hit a six
calm and use code word Joey's church to
get 20% off of some really cool paper
pens